if a transphobic tweet is defined as if
you were able to see it from the
perspective of a trans person would you
feel the organization is welcoming which
trans people will be making the decision
on if they feel my tweet is unwelcoming
is there a board of trans people that
come together and decide what is
offensive and what is not also I'd like
to clarify the policy of trans women
competing in women's sports for
volleyball England this would be very
helpful so I can make sure I know what
I'm responding to and how it'll be
handled
Pearl if your lack of understanding is a
transgender policy is relevant I suggest
you consider putting that in your
response I've attached the so why this
should be an easy question where are the
trans people allowed to play where